اهلا بكم الى موجز لاهم الانباء ارتفع عدد
ضحايا حادث تصادم قطري ركاب شرق الهند الى
288 قتيلا ونحو 900 مصاب وقد وقع الحادث
بولايه اوديشا وذلك بعد خروج احد القطارين
عن مساره واصطدامه بالقطار الاخر واعلنت
السلطات في الولايه انتهاء عمليات الانقاذ
في موقع الحادث مرجحه ارتفاع عدد القتلى
كشف برنامج المسافه صفر في تحقيقه
الميداني الجديد الهند من اشعل الفتيل كشف
بالوثائق والمستندات عن وجود تنظيمات
هندوسيه
متطرف تستهدف ممتلكات المسلمين بعض هذه
التنظيمات يتم تدريب افرادها من قبل الجيش
وقد تمكن فريق البرنامج من الحصول على
شهادات لضحايا مسلمين تم احتجازهم في
معسكرات اعتقال بحجه انهم مهاجرون غير
شرعيين وذلك ضمن خطط تهدد نحو 700 الف
هندي مسلم باسقاط الجنسيه والترحيل وفقا
لتعديل جديد على قانون المواطنه وقد نفى
متحدث باسم الحزب الحاكم اي ممارسات تمييز
وقال ان الحكومه الهنديه ترفض العنف
قال وزير الدفاع الامريكيه ان المحادثات
مع الصين ضروريه للحد من امكانيه اندلاع
نزاع وعبر اوستن امام منتدى شينجريلا
للامن والدفاعي في سنغافوره عن قلق بلاده
من عدم استعداد الصين للمشاركه في اليات
افضل لاداره الازمات على الصعيد العسكري
وفق قوله واضاف ان بلاده تتعهد بالابقاء
على الوضع القائم في مضيق تايوان
هذا واعلن مسؤول عسكري صيني رفيع المستوى
رفض بجين تصريحات وزير الدفاع الامريكيه
بشان الوضع في تايوان قال الجنرال
اين الصين تؤكد سيادتها التي لا جدال فيها
على جزر بحر جنوب الصين والمياه المجاوره
قال حاكم مقاطعه بالقرود الروسيه ان
مدنيين اصيب بجروح خطره خلال تجدد القصف
الاوكراني على بلده شبكيني الحدوديه مع
اوكرانيا وكشف ان السلطات قررت وقف حركه
القطارات والسيارات باتجاه البلده حتى
الثلاثين من الشهر الجاري بسبب الاستمرار
القصف على البلدات الحدوديه
في السودان تتواصل المعارك بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع في المنطقه الصناعيه
ومنطقه اللماب غربيه مدينه الخرطوم كما
شهدت مناطق جنوب اندرمان اشتباكات وسمع
دوي انفجار
اعرب مجلس الامن الدوليه عن ادانته
الشديده لجميع الهجمات على السكان
المدنيين وموظفي الامم المتحده بالسودان
اضافه الى الهجمات التي تستهدف المرافق
الطبيه والعاملين في القطاع الطبي ونهب
الامدادات الانسانيه وشدد المجلس على ان
اتفاق جبل السلام يظل ملزما لجميع
المواقعين عليه ويجب تنفيذه بالكامل خصوصا
احكمه المتعلقه بوقف دائم لاطلاق النار في
دارفور
نهايه هذا الموجز شكرا لكم والى اللقاء